okay hi everyone welcome to another wolf
language design review this is part of
our language completeness and
consistency series
and we have
three topics here
um but all looks straightforward but
those are always
I love the way that that induces an
instant cackle okay yeah
um yeah well I mean I think well as a
jet well I suppose we do have the
occasional straightforward topic but uh
that's right it's very rare okay
right so
um just to bring this all up to speed
right so if you look at that first
framed image right if you click on the w
and P you'll see that right it there oh
both the same size
and they you know are filling up the box
and then because right you don't
rasterize an expression you rasterize a
cell so if you rasterize something it
has to typeset it and then stick it in a
cell and then that's right hold on what
are we actually seeing here we're seeing
oh I see we see it it's it's the full
it's the full Ascender and descender in
every case
basically a full line height right and
the problem with that is that if I'm
labeling a plot with a p it's got a
bunch of you know and it's a bitmap I've
got a bunch of crud around the p
which I would say to the solution to
that is to make the background
transparent and then it doesn't matter
much
yeah I don't know that anyone really
cares about bitmap labeling a plot case
oh you know we do we do care about that
we care about it for machine learning
kinds of things and also uh what I was
just going to say was the case that you
had raised was was machine learning I
thought it was a training scenario
um no it was it's labeling a future
space plot for example
I mean you want me to demo why do they
use bitmaps because that's what it's
look look here's the case
you'd say yes well
okay
okay this is going to use
okay those are bitmaps of those letters
right now we don't see anything bad
happening here but if I were to do I bet
I can even make something bad happen
here
okay that actually looks quite good
because the descenders all you know it
all lines up the baselines all line up
in that case so we win in that case by
having this sort of uh
full font bounding box right I mean I
think the I the issues where you come up
with this is you know if you if you're
doing right if you have like a pain or a
graphics and you know you specify an
image size to that but you know then you
get a you know a couple of pixels off
because of whatever silliness speaks
into it or
um you know that's the case where I've
encountered this issue and I'm not a
hundred percent convinced that the
proposed option actually fixes the issue
due to other issues that it introduces
but
um and the other case is where you might
want
um so if you scroll back up to the wp
example right I think there was some
desire to get a thing that looks like
the third
um
bed map uh this this was an example from
some meeting I was not in
um but apparently where this was
discussed perhaps in relation to eiwl
and so in the third one right they're
both sort of right next to each other
and full size and sort of the issue is
right if you just sort of trim to the
you know trim out the white space then
what does image size apply to so if you
click on the middle frame you'll see
that the W is full height but the p is
simply centered because well it's in a
row but all that white space was sort of
trimmed away all right let's not be what
you want let's zoom out for a second so
wait a minute and and actually the
mismatching sizes I think are misleading
because the uh uh something crossed the
threshold there where the the W ends up
with uh uh the magnification uh some
Auto magnification getting applied
because you know because we apply
magnification to bitmaps that start to
get too small
oh
okay so so if you right click the W
and choose uh uh actual size
and right click and right click the p
and choose actual size
thanks John I oh
okay
then so that matched
height
and then one below matched width is that
right
so then the one below I sort of resized
them both to be the same size as the
original w
um
yeah it it's I actually used uh the
image resize operation below
um
all right but let's zoom out so so is it
is it like just I mean well so if you
take a close look you can see that the
uh the p is just ever so slightly taller
than the W and I think what happened I
mean there literally is a threshold
where it's like you know use default
modification then cross the threshold
and step up the magnification because
the bitmap is considered too small
uh and those steps are discrete in such
a way that it can look very odd when you
know when you cross that threshold okay
but
um
right and so for example if instead of a
p we had an a there then we would have
sort of a centered a in the middle
example correct because presumably will
be less tall than a capital w
yes that would be my expectation
the second example uses image crop so
just rerun this uh the second example
but add an a to it
uh right and then we want to sit have to
do the in actual size yeah
how do you do that programmatically
wrap image around the whole list and say
image size all
right okay so that is is writing
so now you can see the a is
significantly shorter
yeah
whereas the p is you might not have
expected it but the p is like ever so
slightly taller than a capital w
and why is there so much space across
the top even right I've set frame
margins to none and content padding to
false
I'm not
sure that might just be an update issue
after redoing the magnification I'm not
sure I'm I'm not sure what's going on
okay
might be a bug though yeah it might be
okay all right so what is so the issue
here really is
do you want consistent boxing for the
whole font
or do you want shrink wrapping for an
individual element
right
that's right are those the two
possibilities is there anything else
so so
[Music]
um
like I said I you know I don't care so
much about the the the the the texty
case because I think basically what you
do want is in fact something that looks
like a line of text in a Cell
um but what I even get is you know I
create a panel or something or a tape
which I make to be you know 400 by 400
um points I guess not pixels
um and you know then I try to rasterize
it and it's you know 402 by 400 you know
after I've adjusted converted between
points because that extra little bit of
stuff around it
um
you know from being actually part of a
cell
um
is is an issue but I don't I'm not sure
that this actually solves that problem
well it's it it uh solves it by
introducing a potential new problem
which is that you might end up with uh
something that's like 390 or 380 instead
of 400.
foreign because it would effectively
trim off uh you know the unused space
around the edges which could include
part of that 400 width right that you
had specified
or 400 Heights sorry
okay so hold on content padding does
seem to be the relevant option here
correct
well it's an option for things like
brain it's it it's a box option right
thank you
but its functionality seems relevant for
this
isn't it
I mean it's the thing that makes these
guys different sizes
it seems like it's the right option that
you picked yeah well it's it's a it's a
little weird because I mean it's been
exclusively used as a box option not an
option to a kernel function that
actually makes transformations
now maybe that's not a strong enough
argument I mean look it
seems like it's exactly the same thing
it's doing here
well I mean I would say it's a little
different right because it's
the difference between you know
what I'm adding this extra layer do I
put a buffer between
uh uh
the the Slayer and
you know this new this new rapper and
what was already there versus you know
do I somehow shrink to what's visible
I understand but isn't that exactly what
this is saying it's either using the
full line height I see not at least one
full line height what is a line height
is a relative to the font height
right
right line height is defined by the font
okay
so
okay so what's wrong with just having
this content padding out of true or
false would that would that get the
functionality we want so concept padding
our content padding Arrow false we'll
have to rewrite this documentation a bit
to accommodate that right
because it's no longer an option for
objects no I understand that but I mean
but does that okay so the true choices
are it shrink wraps to
um the individual object
right
or
it does it for the line height
and it's it's only height that's
relevant it's not width is that true
correct it's I mean this is basically
that I guess that depends on on what we
want this option to mean and rasterize
um
right because there are certainly cases
where is that true
[Music]
um
if you're asking does content padding
for example horizontally pad
a modest based character to guarantee
it's monospacing I haven't thought about
that question no no the the question I'm
asking about I mean you can certainly
make something
where I'm trying to think of if there's
a case when you rest try something where
the thing you want to trim off is
actually the sides and not the top and
bottom
um rotate the raster
but I don't think that really counts
that's a post rasterize operation okay
the the okay
assume it's not single letters but it's
some whole complicated thing this whole
question about whether there's space
around the bounding box the primary
reason the space being left around these
Bounty boxes is because of font Heights
if we had something like in the example
down below for Content padding of one
half that doesn't have any padding
anyway
see what I'm saying
there is no content padding for one half
there's only content padding for things
which are font things which are part of
a family
they're
yeah there is no there is no external
content padding to
uh to one half there is a bit of
internal content padding
okay but I mean but this content padding
option would apply only to the outer
outermost thing and it will apply can be
applied to the one half just as it can
be applied to the a right
except that for one half there is no
line height
if one half was Tiny compared to the
line height then it would pad to the
line height presumably
right well you know and you can
artificially Force these kinds of
scenarios you can uh you know you can
have uh you know wrap style boxes around
the numerator and denominator that make
those individual things incredibly small
and thereby shrink the fraction below
the ambient font size of the whole thing
so you're saying
take this and I take that for example
just uh
no no no not around the entire fraction
around the individually around the
numerator and the denominator
okay
kind of unfortunate after delete these
double quotes separately
you like me to make this very small
yeah
and the one below and the one below as
well same smallness sure
and
yeah so
oh God that's a big mess okay that's a
good up to eight points
why the heck is that first one
with content battling out of false
I don't get this I don't get what's
happening here so uh type A type
anything next to next to the uh those
boxes
out but out oh oh sorry that's uh this
is a grid okay
um
um
yeah okay okay so so the issue here is
um
the size of the Box around the A on the
upper right
that's the guide
because that's the size of the font for
the grid box yeah
now and because we reduce the size of
the numerator and denominator we
actually made the fraction as a whole
smaller than that size
yes it's not something that would
typically happen if you didn't play
games with the fonts but you can play
games with the fonts to make it happen
but I mean this is the ambient size but
as soon as I put in different styling
for individual elements you're saying
that the grid as a whole gets its sizing
from the ambient Style
not the style of its individual elements
yeah yeah so so all I'm saying is the
Box on the lower right is coming from
what a 15 it's based on a 15 Point font
I think it is uh whatever the ambient
font size is I think it's 15 in this
case
um uh and not the eight point guys that
are found at a deeper nesting
yeah that's all I'm saying
I understand so everything is based on
the 15 Point thing so this thing this
whole whole box Arrangement is based on
that which is why there's all this empty
space yeah yeah exactly
I'm not I'm not saying I'm worried about
this case I'm just saying there are
exceptions and they look like this
yeah okay
okay so let's come back to what we were
talking about
so
I mean this definitely should go into
possible issues for this thing but but
um
Okay so
the concept is content padding Arrow
false
does it
sort of one letter at a time one the
what you see is what determines the
padding as opposed to content batting
Arrow true which is what font you're in
determines what padding is that correct
yeah
seems okay to me anybody got an
objection to this
nope okay
[Music]
um
I well I still
I mean I I guess this is I I I'll just
reiterate I guess that it is a bit weird
that this thing that
you know was sort of a box level option
is now being turned into a kernel
function option
um I don't consider that that weird it
seems like it's doing exactly the same
thing
[Music]
um
as I'm missing something
I mean it literally seems identical
um
check it out trying to remember but it
looks identical to me and I don't see a
problem it's only us that knows kind of
what's a box option versus A disruption
versus that option it just doesn't seem
problematic to me
anybody want to comment further on that
who's here who would have other I I I'm
not objecting so right same here I think
it's fine
okay okay
carried onto the next item
test applied
yes so this is a very this is like like
from two years ago or something
um but there's a prototype of it here
basically the the function is you know
in the family of operator applied and
stuff like that sort of a function that
eats a function and its main purpose is
you know if you have let's say a chain
of compositions and one thing in the
middle of the chain might return a
missing or a failure or something like
that and you want to be able to sort of
pass it down the chain
to do that or up the chain rather I mean
in other words
by
test applied
it lets you do the the idiom you know if
hash if missing Q of hash then hash
otherwise F of hash
it does a little more than that but
that's like the the simplest case right
so if the test
if applying the test succeeds then run
this function otherwise run this
function here
right so that's the complete yes
right and then there are implied
defaults for uh for the third argument
and the second argument right so that
the two complicating things are I mean
otherwise it's a very simple function
the two actually maybe three complicated
things one what's a failure right now
I'm just following what confirm does
um which it's like failure cue or
missing Q or if it's dollar canceled or
dollar aborted or something like that
um the the next thing is uh what the
defaults are for the different arguments
arguments two and three and the last one
is the verarks behavior if it has any
okay so the basic point is in the case
where I just give
okay hold on let me understand this
there's by the way there's an
implementation if you run the init thing
that'll probably be useful
where is that below right right below
it's the the why I told you you should
run run the init cells okay okay fine
all right so then
okay so here
this is only going to fail
what the hell is that it's only running
square root if the thing is positive
yeah yeah right right so I remove that
and now it's only going to trigger on
the missing
yep
well and a default Behavior passed it
through unchanged
right I understand as opposed to if I
said square root of missing
you get square root of missing yeah
right
so a really useful example that shows
potential varic behavior is right right
this right um you know test applied of
divide
comma hash two is not zero
uh yeah just that and then map that over
you know
some some you know list of lists where
some of them might have a zero in the
second argument
I wanted to Triple that
sure
oh yes yeah
[Music]
um
oh no no I don't want to do that no no I
don't want to do that you were right
it's just about
great no uh no no it should be triple uh
of two there
and then no it should be Hash Hash two
this is I was trying to show the vararks
behavior I'm so confused why it's not
even
showing that can you just replace the
test replied with an F just so we can
see what's going on
and and you should do triple at instead
of
Ampersand slash at
get rid of the Ampersand for sure
that's probably the yeah that was a
problem that was the Ampersand was oh it
was there there yeah okay yeah
right so you see here
basically the all three functions the
third argument is is kind of irrelevant
I mean it's basically the what to do if
it fails but but basically all three
functions are all their args and they
all just take all the arguments that get
passed and testified
so the test gets to see all the
arguments the function itself gets to
see all the arguments and so on
right
I see okay yep
I mean this thing with divide for
example you know I've written a million
times
yeah
okay let me think about this for a
second so this is
by the way the confusion that we all had
about the fact that this needed a
function that this itself the test
applied was itself a function
I don't think the name test applied is
obviously horrible
well it kind of makes it sound like
you're applying the test but yeah
exactly
right
then applied
there was a notebook I mean again from
two years ago there was a notebook we
spent like like an hour or something
talking about names for this and one
other thing and there were a lot of
different ideas for it so if we're going
to talk about naming we should get those
up but yeah find it
yeah of the I'll Define it real quick
thanks it's on the the jira ticket
okay I might be able to find it too let
me just try typing this
well we're also talking to some other
things like replace missing and so on
this is the beginnings of supplied here
that's way newer isn't it
I have no idea that's Supply I remember
I looked
I wrote this like I think November of
two years ago like November of okay 2020
or something like that
oh my God that was already during the
pandemic period wow
we'll just
um okay the the
ah Avery you found a bunch of these
is that did you find everything do you
think
let me send you a notebook yeah there's
a lot of names you had
the Q words are not right
right well that that's because we were
talking about that there were two that
another thing we were talking about
which isn't here was basically having
what we eventually I think decided would
be a two argument failure to argument
failure cue
for asking you know because right now
failure Cube basically just checks does
a dollar failed or is it underscore
failure but the idea is we'd have other
versions that also check if it's missing
and also check if it's whatever else
okay that's a different discussion
though what is when you have a test is
is it it's confirmed test right that's
the version of test confirmed by
uh
okay
I mean we could have something like
apply if
all right like apply this if this
condition is met otherwise don't
unfortunately it's a little bit it's a
it's a construct non-apply
no it's a Ply isn't it no it's not well
now it's construct
okay construct takes you know F comma x
y z and constructs f of x y z this is
apply of f of x y z turns into f of x y
z
can you run apply of f of x y z I'm not
sure actually if the level specs all
work out but or like like if it's by
default at the right level but
is there any function though that does I
like I think this is a Ply it's just at
the wrong
or maybe or is it operate or something
okay it does that
yeah but that that is uh
wait let me look I'm pretty sure this is
constructed because it's isn't it
constructed I don't think it's construct
no it's not construct because construct
will be f of x y does that yeah whereas
what we actually have there is no name
it is it actually does have a name it's
called identity identity of f of x y z
returns f of x y z
uh at best it's maybe operate as close
actually you know operate is it would be
operative F comma well I know that's
this I've come with a list next one yeah
okay well is this like operator a plate
or something with some uh
maybe that's where this name came from
but uh right like
um yeah it's like operator applied but
it is but with useless arguments yes if
you tell it to do to just pass through
everything right
you know I gotta tell you test applied
is not the worst name for this
well let's look at the pipeline let's
look at what one of these pipelines
would look like give me an example of
something where we say image crop
we still have shardy here not Charlie
drop my image crop doesn't usually fail
right here I mean if you give it a good
arguments it'll basically I just want a
pipeline work where you've got to give
you know some standard the most common
examples I have are either things where
there's a missing in the middle or like
a zero that you don't want to divide or
an infinity or something in the middle
so for a missing anything with entities
you can get a missing in the middle of
anything
right so just give me a real example
let's just type in a real example
let's say from image Boston pipeline or
from any other pipeline well let's say
you're mapping over countries and you're
getting their populations and then you
are
you want to calculate the their density
so you get the populations and the areas
and you divide them but if one of them
is missing or or hopefully none of them
is zero but right run into trouble okay
so let's take this as an example the
only thing is I'm not sure that we're
going to be able to write this nicely as
like a chain of compositions but yeah
let's start okay this this
so that thing there is a function
okay
and you know what I want to do I want to
do a total of this
actually why would I bother with test
applied then I want to do well then the
test apply I think you want to do the
hash of population will almost certainly
work the thing that won't work is
whatever comes next
because the result of hash of population
will be a missing
no I understand that okay so I want to
just do squared here
right but what you should write is you
should write a hash a population yeah
no but the test applied should be around
the squared because that's what will
fail
no it isn't this will give a missing
right that will give it exactly test
applied only checks if they're missing
to the arguments if you want to do that
that's what confirm does
okay so hold on test applied
of round Square here
squared
yeah
right pound the squared Ampersand close
bracket
where in here yes yes testified takes a
function and it makes a new version of
the function that just passes failures
through it
so you you know oh I see I see so you
need that bracket to the right of the
ampersand
pretty subtle
okay and then this thing applied to Hash
of population
yeah I mean maybe compose it if you want
to be stylish because that's we're kind
of talking about chain composition
things here but yeah okay fine let's
compose that which
you mean at Star
yeah and you'll need parentheses I think
and then just map it over like entity
list of countries horribly inefficient I
mean you should just do it uh with
entity value but but whatever
does that work well I don't think that
works no no
but now I have to Amazon that yeah
and then I take the whole thing I have
no idea about the Precedence so look
that's correct for for map yeah
a g-list of country and then presumably
like Antarctica or something will fail
well I I still don't know why Antarctica
is a country here but whatever
now let's say entity list of
I mean they're almost all going to
succeed for population that's that's why
I'm telling you that Darkness I know I
know I know but I don't want to get an
entity list here
we're just answer your list of country
quotes country
I'm just gonna be a lot of places
let's watch our caching in action
well you could do Country Part you know
you could do take of country come up you
know 10 because Antarctica is
alphabetically quite early
why is it so centrally slow
because it has to make 200 requests
um
Let's uh freeze it out so to speak I
mean well you did the real thing to try
is if you do
yeah I know I I know that's the much
more efficient way to do it but we're
trying to write it with uh yeah yeah I
guess you could I guess you could just
do entity value of country color
population and then map the test applied
over that where's Antarctica
that looks like it unless we finally
fixed it and we no longer have uh
Antarctica in the list of countries
um yeah can you just run into the list
of country just to see what the you know
oh there it is there's number nine so
you've gotta
there we go okay okay
right except I have no idea what test
applied means right it's like
I'm taking this test and applying it but
no I'm right I'm not taking a test no
you're not you're not you're not yeah
it's it's it's really it is
most the time by the way you're not
going to pass in a test at all like
you're going to use the automatic test
the default test right I I was going to
I'm not I'm I'm not suggesting this is a
good name but I feel like test tested
apply is at least closer in spirit
I and I'm I'm doing some testing before
I carelessly apply this function
confirmed apply although I don't I
usually don't like the confirm names
that aren't actual confirmed enclosed
functions but
I mean really what it is it's like a
safe version of your function
I mean it's like I mean this is not a
good uh this is too vague but like it's
like saying safe of f and now you know
that f is something that can take you
know
or or I don't know error ignorance but
it doesn't protected of efforts it's
kind of like um uh it's it's it's
sanitized of f
right yeah
well what do you mean it sometimes it's
not the F that's being sanitized it's
the it's the thing that's coming into
that F doesn't want to eat
look right effort's going to reject any
food that has dirt on it so do you so so
should it be sanitized of f
uh that makes it sound like it's
sanitizing
we can either talk about sort of in the
phrasing of f is a function that only
takes clean stuff so please now that
I've told you this make sure everything
is clean or we can talk about it as like
a verb that's like well or we can talk
about in reference to the arguments and
say this is a thing that will clean up
the arguments and give them dat if you
understand what I'm saying but there's
not cleaning it's not cleaning up any
arguments it's just punting f okay sure
yes right it's rejecting
um right we're gonna have a descriptive
term that's describing F or we can have
it as like uh something that's that's
like more verb like
sanitize four of f
no but it isn't you see
yeah it's sanitizing plot or whatever
yeah
yeah it's ridiculous it turns a little
bit like a foreign
just
[Music]
um
so the problem is that we're not like
sterilizing
decontaminating whatever F itself
exactly that's what makes this art a
name
uh but you could you could talk about it
as what would you call a function that
that that should never be given a you
know an error cuddle of f uddled right
um
I mean look protected of f if we hadn't
used protected for a lot of other things
right well maybe it's kind of the
opposite of protected I mean depending
on how you rate how you're phrasing it
right like it's it's
avoid calling off if
it is a version of f
that where it doesn't call the F if it
isn't good
reject all food that looks bad and you
know
another thing that is that looks bad
engage only when it's you know
um engage only when it's something good
right again though to be clear there's
two you can either name it like picky of
s to say basically this is
this is
we're making a version of F that is
picky or we could call it something like
you know uh
afraid of failures of f which is more of
like a tag to say f is afraid of
failures and you should never give it
one if you forget what I mean I
understand yeah although in a sense it's
really unpickify of f right because f is
can now be fed
yeah
missings and they just sort of
that that's not a problem anymore right
well unless you view it as the uh as the
second version where it's we're telling
you f is picky
but yes yeah I don't think that's the
right thing I think I think it needs to
be
uh
look basically this is basically or
should it be pre-screened of f
that's interesting
um I do think by the way this is one of
those names that would be good to be
short
again I think like operator applied for
example I think part of the killers
that's too long but yes
Nick Merson gave the suggestion maybe
Moda monad so maybe apply
or very like maybe maybe a monad
right there's the maybe Monet right
there's a list I gave at the end of the
the section below there's sort of
similar things in a bunch of different
languages I mean it's the same as option
and rust it's the same as optionals and
Swift or like the optional chaining
operator uh Legends to other languages
has these these names yeah their
language actually there are some really
crazy names like rust right rust has map
and they have a thing called and then so
you have your thing and you say dot and
then and I have never there's and then
then there's also then and there's also
and and I can never keep straight you
know which is which
um
are any good right Haskell has Funk tour
man
great that's gonna help everybody
right that's ridiculous Swift is the
best one which is just that if you have
I mean because they they do everything
with methods right so if you have
something that's a maybe basically an
optional type instead of writing dot Foo
to to you know apply the foo method you
write question mark dot Foo
but yeah I see
yeah this is the analogous thing for us
would be instead of writing f of x you
write F question mark
right right so this is so instead of F
at X it would be sort of f question mark
I mean I don't think that actually works
for us but you know uh and unfortunately
we because we don't have a name for the
at really other than sort of the strange
I mean as you say the only name for the
okay hold on so this is f question mark
Open Bracket X would
theoretically work as well again it
doesn't work but yeah right
okay so hold on what is this really
doing this is
um
the heck is this doing
okay what will be the sentence that we
would say okay so we say
blah and put a suggestion into that
okay
well actually what we have to say is
rather this we have to say blah or F of
expert
yeah you know basically it just gives f
of x
f of x bar if x bar
is not considered a failure
an expert otherwise
yeah
okay come on there's a way to do this
okay what is this doing this is
it's wrapping f
to say if you don't like what you're
being fed
just spit it out
what about something like unsuccess
unsuccessful unsuccess on o n
right so on success run this yeah
I think it's weird to think of two as
being success
mm-hmm well but imagine you write on
success of f you know of entity value of
blah blah blah so you're saying if the
entity value succeeded then do this yeah
but I know but the success seems to come
from the wrong place it's kind of like
like
um
well there's also the question of what
about the you know the Divide case right
I want to apply divide you know if if
one of the if the number if the
denominator is zero is that really a not
a success
uh
this isn't there
um
if valid of f if safe of f but it's not
the F itself you see it's if if the food
if if
ain't right
um what's saying F do F if valid right
yeah on condition
well there's some maybe conflicts with
on
okay hold on we could call it
conditional and then we would have to
explain how it differs both from
condition and conditioned
maybe we should call it on and it will
just do something baffling if you give
it a message name
[Laughter]
I was about to point out that that we
already have something in common but
then you preempted me right
um
what's another analogy other than it
rejects its food because it's too picky
see because usually the thing which is
confusing here is usually in you know
functional based programming
functions you just you have a function
you feed it something
it just does its thing right so this is
a very weird case where it is
symbolically rejecting it somehow right
it's it's enter it's anorexic of f
I mean but really the thing is it fits
it out if it doesn't like it I mean the
thing is I think most in right I mean
two things I mean the first thing is
that most kind of uh
well I don't know most quote-unquote
clean functions will already do this in
the sense that oh you know if a
function's really been thought through
it'll know what to do when you give it a
Miss say
I mean of course that's not true of use
defined functions and in reality it's
not true of a lot of system functions
also but
um
right and then and I I for one don't
agree that it's obvious that you know
missing plus missing equals missing
right yeah right although this is
supposed to this will hopefully get rid
of some of those situations but yeah
I mean apart from the fact that it's too
long and doesn't really apply to All the
Right cases and has weird words in it
missing protected seems like a not
totally ridiculous thing to have in a
chain here I mean if I had this
and it says except it's not missing I
know it's failure but yeah
Megan this is kind of similar to the
discussions we had about confirm right
we're confirmed was the conclusion of
the you know how do you say something
that's kind of correct
yes I see what you're saying I mean
confirm just does it's a no-op if it's
correct
applied or something like that
again though I I am generally skeptical
of course confirmed that aren't
confirmed
because of that it makes it sound like
oh this is something that needs to be
inside of an enclosed when it's not but
a confirm is a word that has this
feature that it's perfectly okay for it
to be a no-op
because that's what this means as well
may be validated
but one of the one of the ones I can see
on the jira ticket was called uh
conditional applied I don't know if we
have that above
I think that's totally weird because
it's it's a
see it's not the F that is confirmed or
checked or whatever right
foreign
which is why I was such a was suggesting
like
validated apply because the it's the
application that's validated not the F
itself
although I agree that's a bit of a
mouthful
okay what would it be it would be like
input validated the best
but when anybody figure out what is
actually going on there in other words
what does it
foreign
I mean that is to me much more
comprehensible than test applied and and
many of the other
you know names because I'm like okay
right I've done something to change how
it handles its inputs right that that
makes sense uh input validation yeah but
what about validated on its own
it's a little confusing because it is
very synonymous with confirmed
right and and obviously the thing that's
it's not the it's not the thing inside
of there that's being validated so
um
it's that's potential you know potential
source of confusion yes
okay well so input validation is at
least crazy but it's too long so let's
see how we reduce this poetically from
two words to less
yeah I mean I I honestly I I still am a
fan of the things that were like on such
and such but yeah how about pre-validate
again though it makes it sound like
you're validating the function not the
uh
I'm I'm making the connection between
you know dollar pre and
the fact that this operates on inputs
um maybe that's a suggestion that only
makes sense to me but okay so let's
think of some some cases of this okay in
the world of whimsical cases it's a
stupid case right you know you have a
flow of water through a pipe and you put
a grate to prevent you know fish coming
from the from the river
I mean I admit that's a pretty stupid
case but what is the what would you call
that kind of I'm sure there's some
generic words for that great but yeah I
mean I would call that guarded
yes that's a that's an interesting word
filtered
that's not a bad word either oh I like
that because it's
I mean again I suppose there's the
potential ambiguity of are you filtering
the F or the input but and the f is the
thing you see but
um right another problem is no filter
filter for select
but yeah yeah I agree I agree okay the
sieved sieve
um
purified
by the way just guarded was another idea
for confirm I remember long time ago
um
yeah
uh
I've started using I I gave up finally
on using an actual
sort of physical thesaurus that I've now
started using
various websites which the one of the
more amusing ones is the Sun
related words website
I'm not familiar with this
I've seen this yeah
gated
Ah that's
an interesting one yeah
babysat
foreign
kind of like wary
scared scared of f
okay there's some interesting ones here
fenced barricaded well that's silly but
well I mean I I you know fenced is not
crazy in my opinion
yeah but I think that something in that
that General
like heavily fortified something
well it's only fenced it's not it's not
heavily fortified right
but uh
defended fortified check posted right
there's a there's a check really this is
adding a check post
yes
I mean is f in some way strict
no I mean it's not you know
accepting things Loosely it's
well in the sense yeah in a sense in the
sense f is dumb so you know I guess we
could I like these I like terms like
this fenced or something it's not quite
right but something like that
right but I think this this is the I
mean if you imagine in a composition
chain
what what do you think it means I mean
again this is why I like the on blank
ones because it's very clear what it
means in a you know composition chain
right I mean the extreme of that so the
most extreme and I think this is bad is
the rust you know and then and so on
where it's like this is supposed to be
if you're reading your code and you hit
this in a chain of composition that you
say the word and then blah blah blah
which I think that's that's too much but
I think if it a little bit of that can
can be okay
qualified
it has a degree or something yeah
I think there's something in the fence
barricade not stockade
caged
and closed
well that's taken
oh yes
[Music]
um
I don't know I think I think the prison
words I think are all kind of hit
I don't know I don't know but I
understand but but I think I think it in
it's fenced for its protection
for some reason these closed metaphors
seem strange to me and open metaphors
make more sense like like things pass
through it
it won't get choked up on a missing
okay it's the identity on missing
operation or on missing Expressions oh
yeah so that's what's
okay let me try a completely different
category
something like that
no that's not right but um
it has an override
we talk about sort of short circuiting
if you give it something it doesn't
understand right
bailsafe
that's not a terrible word that's not
bad yeah
that's actually pretty good
the S lowercase
I think
and well let me check Miriam Webster but
I'm pretty sure it's one word
okay uh online it first shows up with a
hyphen
but then I think also as uh I'm sure
it's smooshed
[Music]
says it's Dash
tough luck okay that which dashes
smooshes
think website
wiktictionary also has it as one word
the evidence both so
so one word is the direction it's going
always
yeah that really is true that really is
true
over and over again that happens all
kinds of with all kinds of words
can you think of any that go the other
way
I can't no
I mean I can think of some where there's
resistance for a long time
you know a lot of ambiguity and cell
phone one word versus two for example
still
yeah but I mean this thing's like
re-evaluate where it starts looking very
weird there must be ones where you have
triple letters if you smoosh
failsafe is quite good
definitely the best we've had
it's really quite good I think
so in a chain you'd have it like
you know fail safe of divide come up
hash not it's not zero or something like
that
I mean we'd say Fail-Safe
I like this this is okay I mean this is
really quite um
and no I think this works
aiming is hard
test applied to Fail-Safe is not a
trivial transformation
okay is there any other
um there I mean there were a couple of
minor points worth uh okay let's look at
this okay I like the name fail safe okay
so the way the description would be
um
makes
fail safe
of f
applies
F to expert in a Fail-Safe way
that's not a good usage line yeah giving
giving effort doesn't really matter I'm
just making it up to see that the
sentence Works giving f of x but if x
bar is not considered a failure
blah blah blah blah
all right let's look at the other cases
here because that this name May inform
the other cases as well
yeah
okay so the main question is is right so
I think
right so the the two questions that sort
of okay there's the should support their
args and if it does what is the test
applied to
right so one version would be the uh the
test gets applied to every argument
individually so you could write
something like missing q and it would
check if any arguments are missing
the other version which based on some
experiments I think makes a lot more
sense is the version here where it's the
test gets applied in a varrog's way to
all the arguments and that way you can
do the hash two it's not zero case and
and okay so this is this case failsafe
of f of x y z that's the case you're
considering yeah
well I mean clearly the default has to
be if any are missing
the hell do you give I mean in other
words
the default one checks if any of them
are missing and if any of them are
missing it Returns the first one that's
missing
which I think makes makes sense but the
question is more about if you give
General second argument what should it
do because I can't think of anything
else reasonable it would do
[Music]
okay okay the first thing that's a
little bit arbitrary here is
if Fail-Safe
fails on Z
that it Returns the failed Z
yes
let's just remind ourselves the term
Fail-Safe
I think it was invented was it a cold
war terminal was that where it was
invented or was it invented long before
that with trains or something
um I just I'm just trying to remember
what the um personal news 1931
um
which is a cold war thing yeah right
right right
it says causing his Machinery to revert
to a safe condition in the event of a
breakdown of malfunction it's a great
word it's a great name for this for this
functionality
um
see the problem is
in a chain here because this isn't
really okay
inserting this verag's form is there a
curried way that you would insert that
barrage form because normally the
reversion to a safe condition
we only work when there's a single thing
that you're passing through
it's not clear what in it I okay
I would slightly make the argument that
we should not have this work right now
for the multi for the verox case and
here's why because I think we're going
to have a more sophisticated version as
we get these string diagrams and other
forms of of kind of functions returning
more than one thing
multis and all that kind of stuff
I have this feeling we might want
something more sophisticated for this
I mean I would argue if a function turns
more than one thing the next function is
still going to get it as an argument
right I mean like
we already do have a way of functions
receiving multiple arguments
yes we just don't have a web functions
returning multiple arguments well we do
the way you compose things is using
apply but yes
right
well okay so let's consider the case
where it's an auditory test yeah right
that's what I'm going to say so I mean
even if even if we decide that it's too
arbitrary and there's nothing to do in
the what argument case I would still
argue the hash is not equal to zero
example is useful enough that it's worth
still supporting a Fair Oaks version
when you have an explicit test
right so you can have it so it only
accepts a single ARG if you don't give
it a test but if you give it a test it's
bear args
hmm
well I'm going to give you an argument
for okay here's here's a question
if it's Fair Oaks if the test is fed
their dogs
how do you determine
gosh do we not have a way to do this
in a a function
with hash hash and so on how do you
determine the number of arguments it's
given length of list of hash hash
oh yeah yeah right right right
that's fine
I guess length of holes complete and
hash hash because we don't know if your
function of attributes but yes
that's patentry so yeah right
seems reasonable to me I agree with you
that the case all right
so the only thing that is is bothering
me as arbitrary is this business about
return the first one that you know what
so what is the default test oh actually
so sorry so there's there's a third
argument that's relevant for the return
thing so there's a third argument which
I think should also be varrods it should
also take the exact same arguments as
the first two and this is what you what
you run in return if you uh if it fails
right so actually if you if you scroll
up to my bullet points I I have a couple
of comments about the
the uh the the those additional
arguments
right yeah
um right so right now the the right the
second argument currently acts as a
supplement rather than
uh a replacement for the uh
um I think it acts as a replacement
um
it should it should be a replacement if
it isn't then it should be
oh is it Missy is it that Miss does
missing of missing turn into missing is
that why what confused me because that
example there seems to suggest that
oh the one with the
uh well which one
so the
oh positive returns false on missing if
that's what you mean I think I think
that's the or it's checking True Q so
positive of missing probably does not
return True Q uh oh that's okay but yes
you're right that example is a little
bit broken then
okay okay so wait a minute what was the
point the point is that that
the question is is it's still going to
fail is the test replacing the test the
checks for failure are missing or is the
test that checks are available
it should replace it yeah it should just
replace it right but but the default
third argument was sort of confusing the
issue
right because notice that the minus 10
turns into a failure object but the
missing just turns into a missing okay
could somebody tell me what is the
default test well well no so sorry that
missing there
that missing there did uh never mind
okay yeah I mean because the the default
test would normally be failure queue but
it isn't if it's Fair Oaks
well it's not fair well it's not
familiar with you either right right
it's it's actually like any true of list
of hash hash comma failure queue but not
failure Cube it's more bigger than that
but yeah
you can look at the code is like 10
lines long for this you can just open up
a pod if you want to see it
right and then there's also automatic
behavior for taking you know for for the
third argument for taking all for for
basically uh if you use the default test
the third argument is basically just
gonna say find me the first thing that
failed the test and return that and if
you're using anything other than the
default test then the third argument
wraps everything in a big failure object
you know awesome on our livestream is
making an interesting suggestion they
say failsafe should return the preceding
term and fail fatal should hold to
execution
phil9 should return empty or null object
we don't really quite have a null object
well of course but here
in a sense what we would have here is
Fail-Safe
and we already have many mechanisms to
Halt execution right that that would
just be confirmed
right
we still don't actually we still haven't
really done anything with untagged
unenclosed confirms but that is a
potential Behavior
but it's even not clear where you
returned to I mean yeah I know I know
it's for some return to the top level of
quote-unquote top level
right okay but anyway so so we're back
to
all right so
I'm just a little concerned okay so the
second argument
you know it will be easy to have a bug
where you didn't consider the varrogs
case and you just gave a name here and
you didn't say of hash one
you see what I'm saying
right yeah yeah
I mean that would be an easy thing to I
mean it's a nice code assistant thing to
check for
but okay so
you've got that
the thing is I think they're
it's a little bit of a there are two
kinds of Errors there are errors that
you know happen and there areas that you
don't know happen so there are errors
where it's like well I'm going over this
list I know the list contains missing so
I need to handle them in which case the
you know I think the danger of oh whoops
I applied it to 10 arguments isn't
really a problem because you're you know
we're sort of assuming
you know you know where they the
failures are and you're you're targeting
known failures that's as opposed to the
case of the you know I don't know where
the failures are but I'm going to try
and bulletproof my code in which case
yes it will be a problem if you you know
that that would be an issue
I think we've got a winner here I think
we pretty much know what this has to do
I think test fund is overrides anything
else and is varrogs fail fun similarly
uh
you know the default fail fund is return
the first failure
right although other than then no that's
not going to work because test fund hold
on that's not going to work I know
yeah right so if if you're using the
automatic test fund I would argue it
should be the first failure because that
is fine
to return something direct fine yeah
non-automatic test fund what does it do
I think it returns a failure
I see a manufactured failure right you
can see that's what it did here so you
see in the first example you know the
missing not available just returned
immediately otherwise he gave us failure
and by the way are we shy I'm sorry I
was muted I I right I was I was
surprised by by the fact that uh
the right that the missing came through
is missing but those -10 came through as
a failure object well I think it's
because right it's because there's a
test an explicit test given right yes
right so so so right so it's not that
it's not right I misunderstood what was
happening but you know now that I
understand I I I will just reiterate
that it is potentially confusing that
the default thing will you know give you
miss I I expected you know either both
the failure objects or you know a
missing and a minus 10 there I know
maybe a minus 10 doesn't make sense
yeah so I just looked at the code so
actually what the current implementation
does is a bit weirder right than what I
was saying the current implementation
just looks at the arguments if any of
the arguments are obviously failures as
in Failure Q missing Etc as in will be
triggered by the default test then it
just picks the first one of those and
returns that if none of them are obvious
failures then it wraps a failure object
right so I think probably would be
better if it just it just always if you
give it a test it'll always do a failure
object and if you don't give it a test
it'll always just pick the first one
I think that's right yeah
I'm okay with that
okay
all right we got a good name for this
this is a good name
mm-hmm
the
um
okay
what's up I would like to propose that
we end here because you know it's 5 35
and I I don't think the echo thing is
going to be a short conversation
you just open it up and just see if it
could be a short conversation if it's
not I agree with the end
given the amount of text
yeah
it's an important conversation but I I I
right I'm I'm you know I'm perfectly
happy to start this you know at the next
LCC meeting uh assuming nothing super
urgent comes uh comes up but you know I
I'm just saying I I would rather not
start maybe we should just quickly while
we're ahead because we've got a good
name yeah
uh
okay sounds good well that's uh happy
holidays everybody and uh I don't see
you all before then see you later okay
thank you